scene three take one mark with this show
we have so many different angles and so
many different cameras that all have to
be synchronized
pull the cord honor our baby monitor
which watches our blinking red light we
did the pilots we're like waiting for it
to come around and it just made
everything so complicated so with the
second round I was like there's got to
be something that's made it was just a
wireless baby monitor so I just had to
modify it to run on batteries it's
amazing it's amazing
we're close to our first shot of the day
and I'm hoping it's destructive if
anybody wants safety goggles I recommend
safety goggles
there's a new thing is a shame say this
is a safe specifically meant shame to
lose in case the iPhone
it's said that my position even needs to
it is you know to degree but I'm
grateful for it because I mean just it's
just so cool to see like all the
generations of the phone it's extremely
photo
Yeah right before they died now when
your evening crunch
I think the case that doubled in half
that was probably the craziest honking
yeah
we're about to drop and once before go
there's locked and loaded Pierce Brosnan
Pierce hang on it's like kind of
beautiful yeah that's right
I was Xbox 360 my personal xbox 360
because the one that we bought on eBay
red rings like the day before shoot
you